what's going on guys today we're going
to be discussing the realistic
possibilities for the future of attack
on titan
now that the manga has come to an end
i'll be breaking down the likelihood of
us ever getting a sequel series or a
prequel series
however i'll start by saying that if we
do get something it won't be isaiah who
does it
there are two main reasons why i'm sure
he'll never return to this universe
with the first being the intense
lifestyle that comes with writing
something like this
back in 2018 he gave a revealing
interview during a tv documentary
in which he frequently commented about
how tired he was all the time as he'd
often do all all-nighters trying to meet
the deadlines each month
the makers of the documentary observed
him during the day and they noted how
they only saw him smile once the entire
time
and that was when he took a break to
play his nintendo switch the full
article is in the description if you
want to read it
but clearly drawing attack on titan was
a stressful experience
and i doubt he'd willingly go back to
their lifestyle this is a man who drew a
new chapter every month for over a
decade
and he only took a break due to the
pandemic in 2020 so if anyone deserves
to hang it up forever it's gonna be him
the second reason i don't think he'll
return is due to fan backlash over the
ending
as it is something he cares about when
he was writing the final few chapters he
was reading people's comments online
which is nearly always a bad idea
and what that shows is that he genuinely
cares about what people think so
it must have hurt a little bit to know
that a decent amount of fans didn't like
the ending
obviously not everyone hated it because
if you look at the sales the final
volume did sell out quicker than
expected
although what is undeniable is that
isayama is aware of the criticism he
received
on one hand you could argue this might
motivate him to draw something in the
future
but even if that happens i think he'd
want to avoid any toxicity that might
come with this specific franchise
if i had to bet i'd say he either never
writes a new manga again
or if he does it will be something brand
new where you essentially start with the
clean slates
let me know in the comments if you agree
with that or not but if i'm right that
doesn't mean that attack on titan is
gone forever
much like the spinoffs that already
exists any future adaptation can be
written by someone who is not isayama
and this message in the final volume
makes it seem like at least they're not
ruling it out
the story still has potential for a
prequel or sequel that could be insanely
popular
and for the rest of the video i'm gonna
explain the top three options that would
get people excited
before we get into the top three ideas
for a sequel be sure to hit that sub
button as we are on the road to 400k
and drop a like as it does help out the
video
okay so the most interesting way to
continue attack on titan is to create a
spin-off manga set during the great
titan war
as this is by far the most fascinating
time in ld in history
back when elder conquered pretty much
the entire world the noble families then
began to fight each other in what willie
tiger described as an endless cycle of
conspiracy and betrayal
that premise alone sounds amazing as
each noble family would have had their
own distinct motivations depending on
which titan they had
those with the more powerful shifters
would want to maintain things the way
they are
whereas the family that had the kartisan
for example would likely have less
influence by comparison
a disparity of that nature could lead to
factions being created among the nobles
and you could have storylines where one
group bands together to try and steal
the titan of another
or where there's political disagreements
within a specific family over who's
going to inherit their titan
in my opinion if there was a prequel of
this nature it'd be cool to divide it
into three major parts that show things
from different points of view
the first part could be set before the
war and it would almost like set the
scene by introducing
us to relevant characters in the empire
who were responsible for triggering the
main conflict
the second part could be a full-blown
war storyline and it might be
interesting to see those events from the
perspective of carl fritz
as this guy was so traumatized he just
decided to burn everything to the ground
in the main series he was referred to as
a weak king by the restorationist
but maybe if we saw the things that carl
saw we'd empathize with his reasoning
for what he did
the third part could also be quite
intense as it could focus on the family
that had the attack titan
and the things they went through to
avoid being captured by mali after car
fritz abandoned his people and moved to
parities
all of the shifters except the attack
titan and the founding titan were
captured by the malians so i think it'd
be awesome to see the race against time
to hide the attack titan away
my guess is that the noble who possessed
it would eventually pass it on to a
commoner who no one would suspect of
having a shifter
while the rest of their family was
likely hunted down and killed
additionally you could have stories
about the members of the fritz family
who rejected carl's ideology
or the malians who wanted to get revenge
on the nobles would oppress them for
centuries
the point is there's a lot of material
to work with in this part of the
timeline
and any author who decides to do it
would have a lot of free reign when it
comes to how the events of the war
unfolded
because there's actually a lot we don't
know another idea for a prequel is one
i've thought about in the past
and that's his series entirely focused
from marley's point of view
it could be set around 70 or 80 years
before the mission to invade parodies
and focus on a previous generation of
warriors who had conflicting views about
whether they were doing the right thing
remember it took decades of
indoctrination for present-day aliens to
be as brainwashed as they are
but in the beginning a lot of them would
have been skeptical of the new malian
regime
i'm certain in the past you would have
found more people like zeke who were
pursuing their own agendas rather than
the agenda of mali
uh and perhaps along the way they tried
to convince other warriors to follow the
same path
that's why the current military now
checks if the warriors are still blindly
loyal before each mission
hence why they do these secret
evaluations finally the last idea that i
think would get people hyped is to do a
direct sequel to the event of the manga
but spoiler warning ahead as i will be
discussing the end of attack on titan
okay so back when the original final
chapter came out the last page was
mikasa thanking aaron
and those who watch my videos will know
that i thought it was mostly satisfying
i say that because things were left on
an open-ended note where there was room
to speculate what might happen next
and with armin going to initiate peace
talks things were relatively hopeful
i felt that conclusion was good since it
left certain things to our imagination
and while aaron's actions were
undeniably terrible there was still a
sense that what he did wasn't totally in
vain
however when the final volume came out
it added extra pages that for better or
worse completely reverse some of the big
consequences
and i guess the first one to mention
would be that parodies was destroyed
meaning that the peace talks that we saw
a few pages earlier were largely
meaningless
on top of that despite the power of the
titans disappearing it then reappears on
the new final page
and yeah i initially didn't know how to
feel about this because
i mean to be honest i thought it was
completely unnecessary but then again if
they are planning a sequel then
i guess setting up like this is the best
thing they could have done i think it
would have been more annoying if they
started a sequel series and began with
this
but at least by putting it at the end of
the original series it's like okay we
knew this was coming we knew a sequel
was going to happen
the tree here looks exactly like the one
that yamir first fell into and the
growth takes place over such a long
period of time that we now have no idea
what this universe even looks like
this essentially gives the author of any
sequel series a blank slate where they
can create whatever type of world they
want to see
and the existence of baron creates many
possibilities okay we don't actually
know his name yet but
right now he is the strongest contender
to be the protagonist of a sequel series
and i'm sure he's someone who already
lives on parodies island
despite the surface being a barren
wasteland it's possible he's part of the
remaining people who live underground
and you know based on his final panel
either he or his dog would become the
new founding titan
in my mind there are a few reasons why
he's likely from the underground
with the first being that if he was from
a foreign country you know a child and a
dog wouldn't have made that journey by
themselves
parodies has clearly been in ruins for
many many many years so there are very
few reasons why people from other
nations will want to visit it
especially as nobody on the outside
knows the importance of this tree
to me the only people who know this tree
is special are those who live on the
island
since they would be aware that this is
the burial site for eren yeager
over the years this mystical tree
probably became some kind of urban
legend on the island
to the point where baron ventured onto
the surface to see if the stories were
true
a sequel could initially follow his life
underground where he hears all these
stories
and then eventually it could transition
to him you know approaching the tree
getting the power of the titans and then
meeting aaron in the past dimension
what happens after that is anyone's
guess but obviously because this is set
in the future the world has superior
technology compared to the original
series
so having titans buy by themselves might
not be enough to win any future wars
anyway guys let me know what you think
might take place if baron really does
become the new founder
and be sure to hit that sub button if
you want to see more videos like this
until the next one peace out